[Musique]
quelques minutes pour défendre sa place
donner de la voix pour partir en
demi-finale kimra et de cela elle est le
coup de cœur de sa session des coups de
cœur mis en place par les équipes du
trempelin des voix pour départager les
130 candidats auditionnés ce weekend ça
s'est bien passé au départ j'étais un
peu j'étais un peu stressé parce que
comme je disais tout à l'heure c'est
vrai que faire quelque chose en guitar
voie quand on a un silence
on entend chaque petite chose qui se
passe on fait pas forcément de balance
là on arrive
[Musique]
directement il m'a dit que je chantais
bien que j'avais fait une belle
performance et que je pouvais continuer
trois catégories interprète 17 ans et
moins interprète 18 ans et plus et
auteur compositeur interprète départagé
par un jury de professionnel on a le
critère de la présence scénique de la
technique vocale de on a aussi
l'originalité en fait la personnalité du
candidat qui peut beaucoup se démarquer
et après on a aussi toute une partie sur
l'interprétation de la chanson
et difficile de savoir ce qui se
démarque on essaie d'être le plus juste
possible 50 d'entre eux partent en
demi-finale une 9e saison qui a dépassé
les espérances des organisateurs 400
candidats se sont inscrits loin devant
les 250 de l'année précédente voilà
voilà voilà voilà qui je suis voilà même
si fini dès la l'ouverture des
inscriptions en juillet en une semaine
je crois qu'on était déjà 50
candidatures
en moins d'un mois on était déjà 100 s
inscrits donc c'était assez
impressionnant prochain rendez-vous pour
les candidats heureux ce samedi 25
novembre à la salle jacbrel puis le jury
prendra la direction de La Réunion pour
continuer les
[Musique]
slection